[Music]
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum gotcha ryan
just got you sitting down hey thanks for
listening i hope you uh
had a glorious weekend everybody
deserves a great weekend um
i had a good weekend we had a uh a great
show yeah that's a stage it show
nice if you didn't come make sure you uh
come next time that didn't sound good at
all but uh you know
every time every last saturday of the
month every month every last saturday we
do a
stage it a 2 p.m show and a 6 p.m show
so make sure you come there
um and the band is sunspend we're at
sunspin.com you could book us zuma's
tons of merch all that stuff and our
handles are
at sun spin band everywhere
um last week's episode i hope you guys
loved uh
katie sacko from the mandalorian if you
haven't watched see it's
uh i really enjoyed that one that was a
glorious job
ryan do you ever have those days where
you just feel a little off
yeah hopefully like you're just like you
know you're just you know not that
you're going through the motions but
you're kind of like
foggy a little foggy yep is it just
because when you get older you get foggy
you just kind of wake up sometimes and
it takes you seven hours to wake up and
by then it's already time for a nap
i think it happens in phases so i'm
having one of those weeks too
yeah it's just a weird week but you wake
up and you go oh this [ __ ] again huh
yeah i think that's what happens i think
also you know my dogs
just had eye surgery irv and uh has been
really really slowing down and i got to
start thinking of
you know down the road it's probably
it's the first time it hit me that my
dog irv i might sometime have to do what
you have to do when the dog gets
you know put him down um the first time
i thought that was last week and i just
looked at him and he was struggling so
much with his walking
and i just started to go
you know he's you know he's 70 percent
deaf he's
his vision is bad it's like when does it
he's
really 13 years old they live till 10 to
12 for this type of dogs and you start
to go hey
i'm not going to torture this guy like
my grandfather who died of alzheimer's
i'm not going to [ __ ] watch him
deteriorate
and and i couldn't do anything about it
the only times i prayed at night
i said god please take him peacefully in
his sleep
he does not want to be alive i know my
grandfather please take him away
i would always like pray for my
grandfather to pass away because i knew
he
that he would be like what the hell are
we doing
what is this i i don't even know where i
am you son of a [ __ ]
you know and i feel like irv you know
gave me that look a week ago he was just
like
hey dude um this is kind of starting to
suck so be on the radar have you have
your radar on
so anyway i love my dog irv and i'm
gonna keep him as long as i can until i
feel like he's had enough
and uh i think it's a mutual thing too
we both kind of like going hey man this
is like
uh you know it's it's enough is enough
there was a song in the 70s
enough is enough is enough i can't go on
i
can't go sorry to bring you down oh my
god hey thanks to all the patrons out
there the patron love if you want to
join the [ __ ] amazing family i just
dropped an f bomb i don't do that a lot
but uh it's patreon.com inside of you
p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com inside of you and uh i always
message you afterwards and i just love
the support from my fellow patrons when
someone else joins and they're welcoming
and there's all sorts of fun [ __ ] there
and um also new merch on the inside of
you online store we got
awesome white mugs they're badass
awesome white like sippers tumblers
white t-shirts are coming and white
beanies are coming
fun so the mugs and tumbles are here
they're really cool we wanted to just
try a different color because usually
black it's usually this let's go
try not to ship it with the new red wine
is all i'm going say red red
wine yeah that wouldn't be a good idea
we don't ship the red one you can't ship
alcohol can you i don't know you can
[ __ ] alcohol
um what are the handles for the inside e
podcast and please guys if you're here
and you're in the mood for zach braff
i'd love for you to just uh
subscribe and write a review on apple
podcast or watch on youtube and
subscribe
it helps the show enormously and if you
like the show
and you actually at the end go you know
what rosenbaum you did a good job i'm
going to subscribe
that would make me feel good and it
would really help the show so i hope you
do that
what are the handles rod right uh inside
of you pod on twitter
inside of you podcast on instagram
facebook youtube.com
inside of you with michael rosenbaum and
it's right there right there you can see
it
it's beautiful the graphics uh thanks to
everybody out there for listening and
continue to listen and we got great
guests coming up today's guest
i love having him on he's a neighbor of
mine i have only seen him once in 18
twice in 18 years so not that
close of a neighbor but a great guy a
genuinely great guy and after talking to
him for the first time
really uh you just you see how genuine
he is
and humble i appreciated him being here
some great stories um
you know and from scrubs and um many
movies
i mean did he get nominated for an
academy award well garden state was a
big right
yeah i mean that's what i'm saying i
mean and uh he just did a big movie with
robert de niro in the stories he has
are just beautiful even stories about
morgan freeman when he directed morgan
and michael caine
oh yeah uh so enjoy this one let's get
inside of zac
braff it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
look how professional you are well i
have
the rig i have all the gear because of
our my own podcast and i know what an
ordeal it is
and how much better it sounds when you
have the real gear and then just over
zoom
in fact i had the audacity to eat
popcorn on our podcast
and my my social media feeds were
blowing up with people saying please
don't ever do that again
turns out turns out people don't like
chewing in their ear
while yeah that's the thing you know i
always like chewing gum too and i never
understood what people
you shouldn't chew gum while you're
doing whatever and i'm like you know and
then you hear somebody else do it
and they're a chomper and you know what
pisses me off i'll just fire away
go ahead is that you know i eat popcorn
and i
try to be quiet but my friend deneen has
popcorn ears so she's always like
i'm michael i i can't sit near you like
in the theater when we used to be
remember remember we used to do that we
used to go to the theater
the artist was so fun but she would say
i'm not sitting by you i'm like i'm
yeah how could you hear me how could you
hear me eat i can hear you my mouth's
closed
i get so upset because i want to i want
to do the right thing
i know i know i didn't i i knew it would
be annoying to people but i didn't think
that people would be like no seriously i
have a problem i couldn't listen today
so no more popcorn on my podcast do you
have anything that people get annoyed
about or
is there something you do that either
your buddy donald faison or other
friends or your girlfriend
uh did they just get oh i hate when you
do that oh my god stop it
oh probably i'm sure i'm trying to think
of what though
um i don't know i'm sure there's lots of
things but i can't think of anything off
the listening
for instance listening is one that i
have sometimes an issue with
uh i try to listen and my excuse is
always
well listen when you have something
really you can't say that though but
what i mean to say is
look when you have something that is
like i'm here for you
if it's serious i'm here i'm listening
i don't have to listen to everything do
you listen to everything
i i have a pet peeve of being
interrupted actually that's
something i have with with people a lot
and
um and
because i'm just aware that we don't
listen to each other
really that that much and so when i have
one i was what shawn hayes was once on
an episode of scrubs and he
he jokingly said someone interrupted me
i'm sorry i'm not used to being
interrupted
and i thought that was so funny so i've
stolen that like when my friends when
you when you're telling an excited story
and someone sent her up singing i was
sorry i'm not used to being interrupted
and um that's a way of saying shut the
[ __ ] up i'm talking in a joking way
[Laughter]
what's funny is that you just said that
when you don't like that's your pet
peeve you don't like it
and i looked over and ryan looked at me
like like he knows that i'm gonna
interrupt you for sure no it's fine
and this context is fine i'm talking
about when like you're telling a story
or you're in a conversation
and we all do it i'm not saying i do it
as well but i'm saying
you there are people that are egregious
i know i have one
woman i know who the whole time you're
talking you're in a conversation
she said something and then while i'm
talking she's going uh-huh uh-huh
uh yeah uh-huh and i just
that that that's a pet peeve of mine i
don't like that let me let me talk
yeah that happened to me in new york i
was working at uh emergency skills
incorporated
and uh you know i'd call places up and i
go hey do you realize when someone has a
heart attack on the job
that you have less than seven minutes
hello hello emergency you know i mean no
one ever you know
and and the woman lorraine i think it
was who worked there
she would i've never heard anything like
this i thought it was a joke at first
but i'd say
she goes um michael did you uh call back
uh
the hospital and i go yeah and as i'm
saying yes yes she's going
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh i thought it was
like a seinfeld episode i couldn't
believe it
i didn't know what to do so i just got
you know it's the same thing man i i
i think it's a nervous tic some people
have they go where they just
they they can't not be talking there's
also
um sentence finishers that's a pet peeve
oh
god uh they're constantly trying to
guess what you're saying and i'm like
that must be exhausting for you let me
just fin i have the sentence it's ready
to go
my friend rob does that and the thing is
no no i do it to rob
where rob will say something and i'll go
because i do know these stories i know
him so well that i feel like i'm like
come on you're [ __ ] taking forever
dude
so he's like yeah so anyway and i talked
to my dad right right
and it's fused now his back's fused he
didn't have to get the feet he goes
no would you let me finish you know
you're 90 of the time wrong and then i'm
in an argument where i'm like
no i'm like 85 right so but you're right
i should not finish sentences at all it
is rude isn't it
well yeah i mean again we all do this
i'm just saying some people are more
egregious than others and i
and i do find that that's funny some
with people in my life who are really
bad at it i'm like ah
your brain is working so hard
to guess what i'm gonna say you've got
four guesses out and they're all wrong
let me just tell you my thought and then
you'll go
this should be a scene you have to write
this this is funny i know i know i
i i you know like everybody i always
think like you just said like oh that'd
be a good seinfeld episode or like oh
that's
that's the beginning of seinfeld was so
great because it could just take a
little irk
a little a little something that
bothered us and then make a whole
episode out of it
right right for sure now you like i have
i deal with anxiety and stuff and i
always talk about it in the podcast but
i read that you you had ocd as a boy and
you know i had attention deficit
disorder do you
ocd is something that you uh you manage
is it something that you had when you're
a kid you lose it
it's gone i i had anxiety just uh first
of all for
ocd is a type of an anxiety disorder
where it manifests in lots of different
ways for people
a classic way for children
is tapping that is to say and i've told
this this
story on on my podcast because we just
did an episode
we just went over an episode where
michael j fox was playing someone with
severe ocd
um i had sort of a more mild version of
his child where i remember
i would have to touch things and tap
things and
if you're wondering what the thinking is
going on in the person or in this case
the child's mind i remember thinking
i know even as a let's say
eight-year-old that this is crazy
but just to cover my bases so i'm safe
i'm gonna do it
so an example would be i'm leaving the
room and we're going out to dinner
and i need to kiss the teddy bear on its
head six times
and if i don't something bad could
happen something bad could happen to my
family
now i know that that's a crazy thought
even as an eight-year-old but i remember
thinking you know what but just to cover
my bases just for safety's sake
i'm gonna do it it's a lot like
superstition like i still won't walk
under a ladder me neither i
i don't think that there's special
forces that are going to hurt him now
but in my brain still i go ah just to
cover my bases i'm not going to walk
onto the ladder
and that that's how the that that at
least that
obsessive-compulsive uh tapping thing
manifested for me as a child now
did your parents notice it like oh
zach's doing that well yeah they brought
me to a psychology psychologist or
psychiatrist i forgot which one and
and um you know he they
they explain it to them my mom was a
psychologist so she was uh in the know
about
about it and then uh i think he said in
somebody's you know this whole
he'll be dealing with some aspect of
this his whole life um just
you know but it's but it's manageable
and then i and then i didn't
i didn't think of it in the forefront of
my brain because the tapping the sort of
the most bizarre stuff obsessively
washing my hands that sort of stuff i
grew out of
um um but you know and then and then you
just
so and then i just you know began to
realize that i was a bit of an anxious
person but that just kind of went along
would feel like
the stereotypic east coast jewish
you know guy we were i was raised on
woody allen movies he was like a
the the icon of of of
of being an east coast jewish american
and he you know he was
cartoonishly neurotic and anxious and
and so we just thought it was i just
thought it was part of being
who i was right and now and now as a 45
year old i i see places where i'm
possibly more more anxious about things
than the average
human being do you think you've gotten
more anxious as years have gone on for
me
i felt like i always sort of say
think in terms of i had more energy so
uh you know i was younger my body could
deal with the stress it could deal with
all these things and then i hit a
certain age
and all this [ __ ] kind of added up and
now
uh it manifests itself and then comes
out
in a different way which doesn't feel as
good sometimes you know i don't feel as
confident sometimes i feel a little bit
um just too much on edge i'm a little
bit wound up uh
the anxiety affects me differently than
it did when i was younger so
do you feel that yes absolutely it's the
same thing i think that
um
it just found a way to peek its head out
in a different way there's a line
i wrote i wrote some of this into my
film garden state um because
it was manifesting itself in a post when
i
graduated college in in a new way
um and i and i was having these really
bad
sporadic headaches and um
i did go to a neurologist and they said
in so many words it sings i you there's
nothing wrong with you and in the film
the the neurologist tells me
you know if you don't deal with some of
these things they're going to find a way
of peeking their head out of the water
and so that's kind of how i i i
felt you know in my early 20s i felt
like i haven't
that doctor as i was a child was right i
haven't really dealt with any
of this in in any way and and i don't
really know how
i mean i can go to therapy um i can do
things that decrease my anxiety
but um at the time i felt really
um scared and and uh
and and um anxious for lack of a better
word about it and and um so that's
that was one of the things that that
created garden state it sort of came out
of
of of all that well what makes you
anxious now what uh
and what do you do about it like what
things make you anxious
the way i would describe it is is that
um
anything that makes everybody else
anxious makes a person with
with ocd or anxiety um anxious
it's just ours our base is higher we're
starting higher
you know you can have like an adrenaline
surge that's the equivalent of you're
almost in a car accident
over something that's that might make
someone uncomfortable or anxious but
shouldn't shouldn't warrant a giant
adrenaline spike
yeah i feel like uh
my anxiousness is this is why i get
upset
like if you're getting upset about
something that seems somewhat
significant
hey you know i have to go do stand-up
tonight in front of a thousand people
and i've only been doing a couple of
months
okay there's you know it's warranted
right but then when you start going
i gotta go get the mail a little anxious
about the mail
i mean not maybe not that small i don't
do that but
there's always a bit of anxiousness with
everything i do
i feel like i'm always a step ahead like
i have to hurry through things
i have to get three you're worrying yeah
you know some of us worry more i think
there's some people who go through life
i always just thought everyone was like
this but i realized now at 45 there's
people that
go through life uh worrying less and and
and being um um
i don't know they can operate
more easily in in a time i mean this is
just such a
you know this time with this pandemic
and and the
economic crisis that's that it's causing
and all of all
every and and of course the politics of
the president and all of that
it's just such a [ __ ] giant
[ __ ] of
of um of anxiety um for everybody
yeah um so it's a very heightened time
yeah you know you
you live down up the street from me we
are neighbors i drive by you and
and we wave um and we finally um well
now we're finally having a chat i'm i'm
i'm really glad about that i am too
and it you know it's rare to see you and
i look at your like you know
everything you've done and it was one of
those things where i'm like this guy
doesn't stop and i always look at like
i said this to dax i've said this to
other people that you know you're
directing you're writing you're doing
i mean there's this list is endless
there's not
you're you don't sit there and do
nothing do you is it very hard for
my my yes very hard for me why that
cause
that causes anxiety for me if you're
asking what are triggers
my agent said it best uh when i was i'm
sure frustrating the [ __ ] out of him my
directing agent i was
probably bugging about some project i
wanted to set up and he was like
you know you don't idle well and i don't
idle well i like to be i'm happiest when
i'm working
i'm happiest when i'm creating um you
know when you do what we do
and you're and you're basically a
freelance
creator whether you're an actor director
writer
singer songwriter you're always waiting
for the next thing
to happen and when i'm not doing that i
i
i i'm i'm not as happy as when i'm doing
it
but how do you handle i just had a four
day i just did a four day directing job
um in for for an amazon show
and it was like mega co it's my only
time i've worked in during covet and
it was all the extreme precautions and
ppe and directing and shields and mass
and
and it was i mean almost silly sometimes
the level of safety which was completely
appropriate and i'm happy about it but
it was crazy directing in a fit mask and
a shield and staying
10 feet away from your actor but my
point was the whole time i was there i
was so happy
i felt like i felt like a fish back in
water you know i just
that's what i like doing i like making
things now
you still have a girlfriend florence or
whatever right yeah yeah you guys have
been dating a while
now you know when you have jobs the next
morning like people work they go to a
nine to five most people in the real
world right
we're very fortunate that you know we
get to go on set and
but still that you know with certain
jobs the work never dies it never ends
so when you have someone or you're
around your friends
is your mind always thinking about
tomorrow is your mind always thinking
about
set lists and and all the things you
have to do is it hard to be present with
someone
and is i mean that's that's what it
seems like if you're always working
then it's hard to just disconnect from
it um
i don't really i think we're both
because we're both um
well this has been it's been on this
this year doesn't count it's funny to
say because
everything's got thrown up in the air
but traditionally um
i think we're both um been people who
are excited about
the things we're working on and and so
we'll we we chat about it and
we want to we want to say oh you know we
read this page i wrote this today and i
think it's kind of
the scene is getting better or or or
i'll run lines with her and
and you know so we we we bring it we
bring it into the relationship we bring
the the
we bring it together and and yeah
otherwise you're off in your corners
are you a defensive person like i think
i get sometimes defensive when someone
tells me
says something that i'm not that i know
isn't true
that's the worst thing you could do to
me i i try to get better about it in my
as i've gotten older and accept
criticism and and and really look at the
situation
um i think that's something that comes
with age being being able to go okay let
me
my first instinct is to be defensive and
and be pissed
but let me let me pause let me think
okay i can see your perspective on that
i mean this is after working on myself a
bunch
yeah and um and doing sort of you know
courses and and and um
you know i i'm interested in in in
in doing work on myself and i've again i
had
my stepfather was a psychologist my
mom's a psychologist my stepmother's a
therapist
so i've had a lot of this stuff in my
life and i'm always kind of working on
myself
so to answer your question i think my
instinct of course like everyone else is
to be like [ __ ] you
but in my head i'm thinking like okay
well zoom out for a second what was
their perception of it how did it come
across
like you know let's look at it from
their shoes yeah well you know i
picture myself as somewhat of a leader
at times
but i do defer to people who are smarter
than me which is most people
and i i a lot of times whether it's a
therapist
and they say when your mom asks for
something or money or this or she's
talking crying about her you know she
has to get a mammogram and she's scared
and and she keeps doing you don't have
to just
give in to this thing and take all this
energy and
and just sort of like just it's
exhausting
so she'll say so it's almost like i in
therapy
i want you to tell me what to do i want
you to tell me what to say sometimes
and she says say to your mother or other
people that do this
i'm sorry to hear that so i started
doing that
and i was like she's like i don't know
his head
and i was like mom i'm really sorry to
hear that and i was like yeah [ __ ] yeah
you just said that [ __ ] yeah you didn't
go on that
[ __ ] yeah and then she's like would your
therapist tell you to say that
damn it you know
uh so those things i mean i think a lot
of times people just want to vent they
don't really want your
your tooth sense i find like a lot of
times people just want you to be heard
and they and you just let them go and
let them vent and and
and you go like wow i hear you yeah that
sucks oh my god yeah
oh i can understand how you'd feel that
yeah and they just kind of want to be i
mean that's why
i mean isn't that what 90 of the
therapist does anyway i mean
occasionally
they'll give you some good uh tidbits
and some good steering but
um but yeah i i i think a lot of times i
i li i think i've realized that a lot of
times people when they're in a space
where they're bitching they don't want
you to be like
here's what you need to do then they get
all riled up and they're mad they
they really just want you to listen see
that you just gave me some great advice
yeah i'm a better therapist than your
therapist but i know certain people
look at me afterwards and i go you know
i'm really i'm sorry and
they want you to kind of come on tell me
what
and they look at you like that's it
that's all you got but maybe it's
healthier it is
obviously it's healthier no i think you
to me i think
i mean if they keep asking you like what
should i do what should i do then of
course you can weigh in but i think
like i think more often than not and
your listeners may disagree but i feel
like people want to be heard
and it's there's a lot what they want is
i hear you that
that [ __ ] sucks if i was in your
shoes you're you're justified in being
upset about that if i was in your shoes
i would be completely upset but
my mom as a therapist
um well as a therapist and a mom would
say to me something that i always
remembered from my childhood which was
she would say you know if if you weren't
upset by that zach there'd be something
wrong with you
and and i and i really i've held on to
that my whole life
i think that's really helpful because i
think so so often we feel like
we're not justified in what we're
feeling and
and my mom as a therapist sorry my dog's
decided now is the time to
to play with the toy right by the mic
that's cute look what's what's her name
that's billy you've seen her in the car
before
if she poops outside your house i always
pick it up
billy's decided it's funny with dogs i
imagine if it's like this way with
children
um she wasn't playing with this toy the
whole day
but i called you and she decided now's
the time yep
anyway that that phrase always stuck
with me which was um
you know if if and and if you're a
parent i think it's great for children
it really
because i always felt heard for lack of
a better term that she would be like
i hear you you know if there wasn't
that's you're so justified in that if
if you didn't feel that emotion and that
happened there'd be something wrong with
you
inside of you is brought to you by
relief band ryan i hate being nauseous
man
if somebody could tell you you won't get
nauseous or i could help you with your
nausea
whether you're you know people get
nauseous women get nauseous for certain
reasons
men get nauseous i get on a boat i'm
nauseous sometimes when i'm on a plane i
get nauseous me too because that feeling
of like you're gonna throw up or you're
a little spinny or you're a little bit
ugh
it's just it's the worst feeling you
know that was about a year ago that
happened i thought i'd grow it out
i grow out of it being nauseous but you
don't it doesn't happen
nauseous happens forever yeah nauseous
nausea yeah it's uncomfortable okay you
can't focus
that's why i'm really excited about uh
our new partner that we just joined with
and that's relief band relief band is
the number one
fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness
anxiety migraine hangover
morning sickness chemotherapy and
so much more the product is 100
drug-free
non-drowsy and provides all-natural
relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
and you know how it works
relief band stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of the
brain that controls
nausea then it blocks the signal your
brain is sending to your stomach telling
you that you are
sick relief band is the only
over-the-counter
wearable device that has been used in
hospitals in oncology clinics
to treat nausea and vomiting i can't
tell you how much
uh this really helps me i can actually
get on a boat now and i don't have to
take pills that make me really drowsy
and crappy
i just put on a wristband sounds
pretty good to me ensure nausea is never
the reason to miss out on life's
important moments
right now relief ban has an exclusive
offer just for inside of you listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use
promo code inside
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and no questions asked
30-day money-back guarantee so head to
b r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a n d relief band dot
com
and use our promo code inside for
20 off inside of you is brought to you
by hellofresh i love these guys
if i want to eat healthy and i don't
want to go to the grocery store orion
i want to just it's all the ingredients
are there for you
it's easy to follow i can do this i know
i can and i did
i made pork and rice and green beans
last night
and it was freaking delicious i had two
meals
well i ate a meal and then i saved it
for the next day nice
i wanted to say i'm going to say this at
the end too but i want to say this now
because this is a blow-away deal if you
go to hellofresh.com
iou 10 and you use the code iou 10
you get 10 free meals including free
shipping
how are they giving away 10 free meals
that's bonkers
if you guys don't know what hellofresh
is you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
hellofresh lets you skip those trips to
the grocery store
and makes home cooking easy fun and
affordable and that's why it's america's
number one
meal kit hellofresh cuts out stressful
meal planning and grocery store trips so
you can enjoy cooking and get dinner on
the table in about 30 minutes or less
eating healthier has never been easier
with cal
carb smart vegetarian and pescatarian
options
every week no matter what you choose
every single recipe is packed with fresh
produce
sourced directly from farmers
go to hellofresh.com iou10
and use code iou 10 for 10
free meals including free
shipping these guys are great they're
number one so
uh why don't you uh pick up the phone or
get online and and get it done
by the way ryan here who you can't see
is my uh
editor engineer he's awesome i love him
and uh he's a big scrubs fan i mean you
have so many scrubs fans but
uh yeah i asked him yeah he says thank
you i guess you have headphones on you
can hear that
ryan thank you very much but his
favorite episode is the uh go ahead tell
him
oh it's uh overkill the one with colin
hay at the beginning yeah
that's a great one thank you thank you
we've been so yeah so what happened was
we were going to do
a a a re i i let me start this
from men at work by the way was on there
was on the show and
and ryan who wasn't men at work and now
has an amazing solo career where he
where he has tons of great songs you
should check out
and he also of course does covers of the
old men at work songs as like folk
acoustic and they're amazing
and um at the time we were making scrubs
um
you know a very long time ago but we had
him on we we used his music and then
because he's sort of a funny character
and and uh and and has had been on i
think the larry sanders show as himself
or something
so we had him on uh in a fantasy
sequence and he was
he was wonderful yeah if i said i can't
get to sleep
what would you say i think about the
expectations
i think it's implication implications
diving in too
deep and possibly the complications
especially at night
[Music]
i'm telling you have you heard his his
like solo acoustic version of that i had
lunch with him last year
uh i i've seen him acoustic a few times
i i just
i love his stuff he's so charming i'm
telling you if you if you guys if your
listeners
if you guys haven't heard go go listen
to some colin hay like um
uh obviously listen to the men at work
songs you might like that he covers like
overkill
but um they're just i just don't think
i'll ever get over you
it's just one of my favorite
heartbreaking colin hayes songs
um beautiful my my my it's a beautiful
world a beautiful world
um he's so talented he's so interesting
and when the world opens back up go see
him live because he tours
and it's mostly just him with a guitar
but he'll tell you know most artists
they tell you a story about the song and
you're like okay get to the song he goes
off on the funniest
stories he's like a part stand up and
you're cracking up about him telling
these anecdotes
and he's done it for so long just like a
stand-up comedian he knows what works
and what doesn't work
and he tells these wonderful stories and
then goes into
a song it's it's really great yeah he's
a great storyteller
you know when you got scrubs obviously
you i i didn't believe this but i mean i
believe it
but six times you auditioned for it is
that true yeah but but
you know that's a lot like that's i mean
i can understand you go in
they want to see you again and they want
you to test but that's
six times i mean what did they want to
see
what did they want to see from zach
braff well that's a very good question i
think
um i was a waiter and i had no i didn't
have many credits i had only done a
handful of things i
but i had nothing they could really look
at and be like oh he'd just been on this
show
um and i was up against a couple of
known people
um that i won't say but i'll tell you
off the air and so i was like i was kind
of like i'm never gonna get this they're
gonna give it to one of these known guys
but so i but then i kept getting called
back and then i got called back again
and then it was like a work session with
bill the showrunner and then it was
uh then it was okay we want to see a
chemistry with you and sarah chalk who'd
already been cast
and then it was then you know how the
end goes you then go in front of the
studio
apparently they're not doing this like
they used to back in our day when we got
going but
for those listeners who don't know when
you go to the studio
a studio test you would then go in front
of like
10 to 20 people and it was so
intimidating
and then if you pass that round you'd
then go to the network
where there could be i mean i remember
for scrubs it was probably 25 people
packed in a small room
and and all staring at me and it's like
i remember thinking it's like the
olympics like it doesn't matter how well
you did it at home it's like you do it
now
or you die and uh and
it's a ludicrous process because i never
understood why you're making the actors
sweat so hard they're not auditioning to
be in a broadway show
you know where they have to perform live
in front of me they're auditioning to be
a an actor that's great on set that that
cuts together well
right so why not now at least when i've
done pilots in latter years there's more
like okay
we'll look at the tape we don't need
that we don't need to have you come in
and and
do this you know tiny room in front of
30 people and
it's so much pressure well it worked out
yes it did how many seasons was it i did
nine
we we did nine good god i left a little
bit early so i sometimes say i did eight
and a half
but the we did nine now obviously you've
directed a ton
you know directed the hundredth episode
you directed i don't know what
30 episodes 20 episodes no no not that
many actually i
thought it was more too and i recently
went back and looked and i think i only
did like seven or so
do you remember when you first directed
an uh episode of scrubs
were you really worried about it's like
now you're directing these people you've
been working with
and that's that's the scarce because you
want to make them think he knows what
he's doing
do you remember that first day or yeah i
had done i had tiptoed in because
here's my tiptoe in was um well first of
all
bill pretty much made fun of me like a
big brother our our show
our show runner creator has since become
one of my best friends and he's a mentor
to me
but at the time we had a very big
brother little brother relationship
he was supportive of me and he loved me
but he was tough on me
and um i think he had an interest
it seems well he's admitted in the past
of sort of keeping my ego in check
because he didn't want to have a
a kid who'd become super famous and
cocky and ruin his life
um so he would do things to bring me
down a notch and
i remember that the line producer said
that i could direct the music video
for this theme song um
and i thought that was so exciting and
bill sort of made fun of me
he said something to quip like oh well
that that should make sure no one ever
sees it
and i really felt like [ __ ] and he did
in front of the crew
and and
i did it and i i said to myself i need
to crush this i need to crush this to
not only show him up and give him the
finger
but also so that the so that the cast
will trust me so i could one day direct
an episode so i just put everything i
had into it and i made a really cool
music video which
i haven't seen in years but you could
check out if you're curious on youtube
and um and then what happened was garden
state this was roughly 2003 then garden
state
happened and garden state had a
record sale at sundance and then he had
to he had to
sort of eat crow and change his whole
tune and then he was like
okay you can direct an episode but the
big brother didn't go away because he
gave me an episode that was
impossible to execute in five days it
was like epically
huge and lots of locations and stunts
and
literally a night shoot on the universal
new york street back lot with a stunt
like as though he was saying like all
right [ __ ] here
go correct an episode yeah it was like
it was you know it was like a 10-day
episode
meant to be shot in five i feel like
that's an ego thing and that's like uh
i'm not saying you know bill's a great
guy i i i've had
other people do that to me you know when
i directed an episode of smallville and
i had there were producers that were
they some people they want to see a fail
they want
they want you or they or they want to
see you struggle and see how hard it is
to
actually direct they don't want you to
walk in there and go oh look here he's
being given the keys when they've worked
their whole lives to do what they're
doing
and so when they you know they say okay
drive
now doing a tv show ever it's a lot
easier than directing a movie and then
hiring the
the crew because everybody knows what
they're doing and so right you know
well-oiled machine by then
right it's easier but i think there is
definitely that
that thought of uh i don't know how many
people in general
do you think people generally go i want
to see him succeed
no you know what my favorite hollywood
quote is i don't know who said it but i
always think of it when when this [ __ ]
happens in my life i go
you want to sum up hollywood it's like
people want you to do well
but they don't want you to do that well
yeah
i i i and i can't even express how true
that is
and if you're thinking of coming here
just know that people want you to do
well
but they don't want you to do that well
i think that's why
i mean and that's on a micro and macro
scale that could be your friend who's an
actor
yeah they're happy you got that pilot
but now they're kind of pissed you got
that pilot because everything's going to
change
or it could be on a macro scale of
you know the media and the internet
builds up a new star
only to just [ __ ] wait five four
three two one to [ __ ] drag them down
man i i'm glad you you said that because
i feel that way and i feel that way even
with like it could be friends
it could be where they really they want
you to be
successful and healthy and there's no
malice there's no but they don't want
you to get bigger than they are
they don't want you to get more
attention than they have
and that is just innately some people
that's just
th that's who they are i i'm sure you
when you got your big break
um had a few friendships disappear i did
yeah you know my thing is is i don't
change in a way of like and i'm sure you
do i mean look you change because
now i'm not living in a one bedroom with
four guys now i'm not
now i'm able to have my own car and now
i'm able to so there's
there's definitely changes but i would
purposely try to do
i'm just always i'm a kid at heart i
grew up in indiana i want to go bowling
i want a karaoke i want to do stupid
[ __ ]
because that's what makes me happy so i
would go to the opposite i wouldn't do
fancy [ __ ]
fancy [ __ ] is something i don't feel
comfortable with i didn't do fancy [ __ ]
dude i'm just saying
that say you did do fancy [ __ ] you know
what i bought the first thing i bought
was a shower
i went into waterworks which is a very
expensive
what do you call a plot not appliance um
fixtures or what you know bathroom and
kitchen fixtures place
and i said what's the most expensive
shower head that you have
in the store right now available for me
to leave with and they were like
this one and i was like i'll take it it
was the first thing i bought with my
with my with my newfound money you know
what i bought
[ __ ] you not there's there's two things
that i remember
three things i did this seven-minute
scene in a movie called midnight in the
garden of good and evil with clint
eastwood he directed me
yeah and i wasn't invited to the
premiere but i thought i'd show up
and i bought myself a suit at fred
siegel i spent for a jacket shoes
everything probably about two thousand
dollars
i didn't have it but i wanted to look
like a movie star
for my seven-minute scene i guess and i
i'm not kidding i'm not trying to act
like oh this is like how could i make
myself i was dropped off in a cab in
front of warner brothers
i walked there and i waited and i saw
spacey who's in the movie oh kev it's
rosenbaum he's like
oh hey how's it going he's like what are
you doing are you are you coming into
the movie or not
and i said yeah no i am just like i go i
don't have activities you don't have a
[ __ ] ticket
just come with me it's fine so i i want
that's a good impression well
thank you and i walked in and that's how
i got in so i spent all that money
that was one thing so that wasn't really
i don't even know why i told that story
but b i told my dad the first times
i bought a galaga machine the full-sized
galaga machine for 800 you know the
arcade game from the eight years i
bought our kid games too i think that's
like
i think that's like a silver sport age
our age uh range uh
nostalgia like first first giant check
you're like what arcade game will i be
getting from my living room
mine was spy hunter oh i love spy hunter
was that the song that's it that's
it you know also i
i remember when uh going in style when
you directed that movie yeah
first of all i was a little bit jealous
i was like oh my god it's one of my
favorite old movies with uh george burns
and
uh lawrence olivier and i was
yeah right and so i remember i was like
oh my god
and the movie was so fun but all i kept
thinking was how is zach
not freaking out directing morgan
freeman michael kane
alan arkin how is he on set every day
acting cool
i was freaking out dude every day i was
freaking out and i couldn't believe it
you know i only made
i'd made two small indies that i that
i'd written uh wish i was here my second
one i wrote with my brother adam
and uh they were all you know they were
they were relatively tiny this was like
a
giant action heist movie with three big
stars
i just kind of couldn't believe it was
happening and i'm looking over at the
poster which is on my wall
and i love them i love all three of them
so much and
and i i think at the time i was just
i just knew like an actor i had to play
the part of confident director
but i was certainly a bunch of times
having to give myself pep talks well
what were the
i i to me it seems like the
and i'm sure he's brilliant not he's
friendly as [ __ ] i just look at him and
oh my god
but alan arkin right i just pictured him
doing that
why are we doing that for we we just did
that already
i just i don't know what he sounds like
but sort of all three of them are big
personalities
and uh it's kind of like a real it's an
advanced
class in directing because first of all
we direct i shot that movie in
in manhattan and brooklyn and for the
most part and
in the summer um and
crowds form i mean crowds form when
you're shooting anything in manhattan
not crowds people are used to it hold on
let me deal with it let me deal with the
crying dog two seconds
baby what do you want from me how about
out here i guess it's good practice
for a kid when you're like how do i
assess what
the dog wants right yeah i think this
was it i want to
sprint in the garden not watch you do a
podcast come back
um so obviously people in manhattan are
and tourists and such are used to seeing
film shoots and everything but when
you're when you're shooting a scene with
morgan freeman and michael caine and
alan arkin
like a crowd forms and so
and paparazzi come and so it's
i'm doing an action movie with seniors
in manhattan and brooklyn
in the middle of summer with crowds
and paparazzi and it was like i just
remember some days laughing being like
this is like
how the hell do we shoot this losing the
sunlight and there's like a giant
crowd that's at least been wrangled to
that corner so we have to frame that
corner out
but ultimately it was a lot of fun and
i'm really proud of the movie i think
that
i mean i didn't i didn't write it i wish
i wrote it ted melfi did a great job
writing it
but um i i you know it was
it was it was in my my audition if you
will just to
to the studios that i could scale up and
make something bigger if i
if i was given the opportunity did you
ever do impressions of them in front of
them
um probably not in front of them
but right i can do one now for you i
remember michael caine coming to set one
day
i i have to get into character huh
michael kai michael kaine
i just seen hamilton and he was he was
he'd seen hamilton the night before and
he's coming he said
you're not gonna it's amazing this one's
talking like this
and the other one's singing like this
it's amazing he was like
giving his michael kane presents
hamilton
his impression of of rapping which was
pretty hilarious and then of course
morgan
chimes because he's not going to be
talking about this again is he morgan
morgan morgan hello this is morgan
freeman he was my outgoing message for a
while because he lost a bet to me and
and losing the bet he had to do my my
outgoing what did he say message
he was like hello this is morgan freeman
zach can't come to the phone right now
please the funniest story was that i
did well first first time we had a i got
them all in a room together
the carlisle hotel this super fancy new
york city hotel and it's me i'm in a i'm
in a suite
that's sitting around a small circular
table
is michael caine morgan freeman and alan
arkin and me
and we're just sitting there and we just
started talking about the movie i just
can't believe how surreal this is but
i'm sitting there we're just shooting
this [ __ ]
we get to a scene in going in style
where the characters get high
and michael kane stops and he goes you
know i don't know if i've ever been
high before i think richard burton got
me high but
i don't really remember what's it like
and then so i start
describing to michael caine what being
high is like i'm like oh you're kind of
giggly and
it's a little bit like being drunk but
it's more a little bit more silly and
and and um and i'm just whatever i go on
and describe it to him and then you know
my eyes pan over to morgan freeman who
just looks at me and goes
i'm a pothead
[Laughter]
that is real morgan it was morgan's way
of telling me like i won't need practice
and if you look at the movie if you
watch the scene morgan
clearly shows that he's had a joint in
his hit fingers before
what uh what uh is the hardest thing
about
success for you like what what is it
that cause people say oh poor guy you
know
it seems like you can't ever talk about
problems because you shouldn't have any
problems if you make a lot of money if
you're
you know you do movies and you do these
things you're we're ultimately lucky and
grateful
as as we are it's hard to to [ __ ] but
what are
what's the toughest thing for you about
um
i mean you've been famous for a while
but what is it is it is it just sort of
well you you could answer the question i
don't know i mean i don't i feel even
stupid answering even after you gave
your
uh your uh yeah i don't know why
qualifier i mean i
i don't have anything to complain about
i think i think
unless you're in the public eye you
could never get used to reading
something
false and mean about yourself um
that some writer took a long time to
write
whether it's a bad review or it's an
article about
you it's just that i don't think anyone
could fully digest
someone or a publication publishing
something super
mean and or negative about you until
you've experienced it
and if you're in the public eye and you
put out things
people are going to write about what
you're up to what's the one thing that
hurt your feelings the most though like
if you read something about yourself
and you like knew it wasn't true or
maybe i mean i don't want to call out a
specific thing because i'll just call
attention to it but i just think you
know
there's times where i'll read something
i'm like wow this [ __ ] person got the
assignment to review my movie and they
clearly don't like
me yeah yeah you know it's like it's not
like my movie's [ __ ] it's like
i'm [ __ ] and i just always
i just don't think i've been i've been
famous quote-unquote famous for 20 years
i don't think i'll ever get used to that
have you ever thought of responding to
them like what do you got against me
in the beginning i used to i totally
used but back in the beginning with like
the beginning of the internet and
myspace and facebook and i would
or even call people sometimes i would
totally engage
um i'll give an example i will give an
example i won't say the magazine but i
once
early on in my success i had a i met
with a writer
who's going to do a big piece on me and
it was a big deal for me because i
hadn't
been profiled you know before and
i spent the day with the guy we had a
blast went around lower manhattan
started with coffee then got a few
drinks then just shot the ship
i'm sure this has happened to you too
it's happened to almost everyone that's
i know that's been famous yeah the
article comes out
and i look like such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i was just i was gabs gobsmacked and
i caught so i
asked my publishers like kind of that
guy's number i'm just i'm curious i have
to call this guy
and i'm like dude this is like a hit
piece what'd you do
and he goes full disclosure i handed in
the story and they said it has to have
an angle
what was my it had no edge to it it had
no angle i i needed to find an angle so
this was
what i had to do and i was like i
learned the lesson early on like
there's this story there's a reason if
you look at huge mega stars like
leonardo dicaprio brad pitt
there's never there's never um they
never sit down for
those those things anymore it's always q
and as it'll say q
a q a q a because they they've
they like well i don't need to do that
why do i need you to go spin how our day
went
you know what i mean yeah and i learned
early on that um people don't want to
read
that me and this writer had a fun day
walking around manhattan doing like a
pub crawl
they want to read an angle they want to
read an edge
that's so true people want you to do
well michael they don't want you to do
that
i don't want you to do that well
inside of you is brought to you by
butcher box
ryan i just got a box full of freaking
meat the most delicious steaks and
chicken and bacon and pork
i was born i've never seen this was the
most beautiful box if you're a
meat-eater like me if you're a
vegetarian
move along this blew me away i was so
excited i cooked a steak
within minutes and it was effing
delicious
so it's very easy every month butcherbox
sends
a curated selection of high quality meat
right to your house
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones each box has 9 to 11
pounds of meat enough for 24
individuals packed fresh and shipped
frozen and vacuum sealed so it stays
that way i can customize my box or go
with one of theirs
either way i get exactly what i want
butcher box is a no-brainer and you know
with the
the super bowl the big game the big game
these guys are perfect because you can
make so many great snacks out of all
this stuff that they give you
and butcher box is offering one rack of
st
louis ribs one pack of bacon and one
pack of pulled pork for
free in your first box i'm telling you
when you open this box it is just
marvelous it's so easy to have butcher
box meat just show up at your door
i open the door and there's a box of
butcher box
each month they send a box of the
highest quality meat for a better price
than the grocery store this is quality
freaking
meat and a better price you heard that
and also it's great to never be without
something to cook
for dinner this butcher box once you get
this big box full of all this great
stuff
is going to last you quite a while and
so you won't have to worry about cooking
and
it just gets right to your front door i
don't think there's it could be easier
than that
technology man it's crazy life this is
what they do now butcher box
is the most affordable and convenient
way to get healthy
humanely raised meat right now you can
get a free rack of st louis ribs one
pack of bacon and one pack of pulled
pork off your first box that's one rack
of st louis ribs
one delicious pack of bacon one pack of
pulled pork for free in the first box
just go go to butcherbox.com
inside that's butcherbox.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by
geico geico's the place to go it sure is
i mean most people probably go to geico
i would agree i could even name another
a place to go
uh but look we are we talk about this
all the time but like you know it's very
simple
i i i own my home ryan rents an
apartment it's always the hardest thing
to do
is to rent or pay your mortgage or
whatever it's always what everybody's
you know it's it's the toughest thing to
do
that's it's hard work it's it's honestly
hard work and what's easy
is that geico has these bundling
policies so
your insurance is you don't have to pay
a home insurance for someone and then
car insurance or someone else they had
these bundling policies and it's very
simple
it just seems like why wouldn't you do
that we already have so much to do
around our homes or our apartments or
wherever we are
just go to geico.com get a quote and see
how much
you could save it's geico easy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
even a rosenbomb can do it
what do you do for fun man what do you
do for uh like you know what makes you
happy
what i mean i hate that that's a bad
question what makes like what what's fun
for you
besides work what is fun i love
um even though i just broke my toe i i
love riding a motorcycle
i i didn't know you rode motorcycles i
do why was i seinfeld there
i know you did i don't know why that
brings me joy
what else brings me joy um being with my
girlfriend brings me a lot of joy
i'm playing with my dog um in normal
times going to the movies going to the
theater
i have a i have a place in manhattan and
i go there often and
spend a lot of the year there in normal
times and nothing makes me happier than
going to dinner and then going to the
theater and then going out for drinks
with friends after that's like my
perfect night if you had a choice to do
theater movies or tv
that's it you get one to do one that's
it i don't care that's it one of them
what is it well now it would be tv
because i think
well you might as an actor or director i
guess or both but then you have to
choose
um well i guess i would choose films
because but
i was about to give a qualifier that now
everything's on streaming but my answer
would be a film
whether it's streaming or in the
theaters um
i love theater but uh it's a lifestyle
it's really hard i did it i did a
broadway show for
six months it was supposed to be a year
but i only did it for six months um
because
it wasn't selling well enough and it
closed but after six months i was like
collapsed on the ground after doing
eight shows a week
um so i love it but it's not something
that i have the
desire to do right now at this point in
my life do you are you able to turn off
let's say you do a show
it finishes you know broadway shows are
like what eight o'clock
eight to eleven yeah you're done
can you shut off the next morning
absolutely not absolutely not that's why
everyone goes and gets drinks after
because
you you i mean i can only speak for
myself but i'm sure
considering the amount of alcohol
consumed by broadway uh actors dancers
and singers i can tell you it must be
not just me
um yeah it's very hard your adrenaline
is going so strong
and it's like 11 o'clock at night and
your body's like i'm not going home
well what about the next day you wake up
are you thinking about that
i don't know it's a weird life because
then you wake up the next day
and you have the whole day free unless
unless it's you know the weekends or or
wednesday
and um but you can't really commit to
too much because you got to be at the
theater by 7 30.
so it's also really hard to maintain
relationships your partner has to be
down with that lifestyle
you know friendships kind of go by the
wayside because you can't ever go to
dinner with anyone you can't ever
unless they come to get a drink after
the show you never really see them do
you get nervous before a show
every show every every single
performance every performer what time in
the day if you're going up at eight do
you start feeling those butterflies
um 7 15. they start when you're in your
dressing room you start hearing them
come over the intercom
saying things like half hour this is
your half hour call half hour buddy good
welcome welcome to tuesday everybody
half hour half hour
and then you're like that's when you're
like oh [ __ ] here we go i gotta go
i gotta go do it who's not yeah every
day every time i think every time i
think i'm gonna fail or i'm gonna [ __ ]
up or or it's gonna go horribly wrong
do you ever go up on your lines where
you're like i i just just
[ __ ] completely disastrous i have
um thank god knock would touch
everything
um not not so horribly i couldn't get
back or or with the help of friends but
that's my that's a huge anxiety i mean
that's that's
you know actors have nightmares about
that what's the most famous person that
ever came to watch you uh you found out
oh look um uh kena reeves is in the
audience they're
here to see you zac um my man crush shot
chris martin
uh came that was a big moment for me
what's your favorite coldplay song oh
it's gotta be fix you
um because it's i i
i love fix you i think and what if and
um swallowed by the sea who's your
favorite band ever
tough question i can't answer that i can
what is it chicago probably
really i just like i didn't say steely
dan oh i like steely dan but you know
why here's the problem with steely dan
don't see him live
because you'll get screamed at by people
behind you with binoculars saying sit
down
so you can't ever dance or anything
you're like sitting there i go i got in
a fight not a
fist fight but i you know i paid really
good money to see steely dan you know
like 40 dollars at least
and uh i'm there and i'm just going i'm
like
go back jack do it again
wheels and the guy's like sit down and
i'm like
i paid good money to come to a concert
and have fun
why don't you watch on dvd [ __ ] it
just it's tricky these concerts
these musicians that fall between
there's musicians
that are clearly sit down performers
and there's musicians that are clear
standing performers the ones that fall
in between you're always going to have a
problem with people being like
sit down that's true all right this is
called [ __ ] talking with zach braff uh
this is rapid fire these are uh my
patrons fellow patrons want to ask some
questions they like you
okay nico p if you're having an off day
what is something you do that helps you
get in a better mood
uh meditate does that really help you
because i tried it for a while
how long do you have to meditate for a
tour 20 minutes use the app headspace
there's a bunch of them but i like
headspace
because i like the guy's voice um just
do it
20 minutes a day in the morning um
not after you've had a ton of coffee
because that defeats the purpose if
you've had coffee
then wait or do it before coffee um
and do it 20 minutes a day for five days
i'll bet you you'll notice it
wow leanne p what's something that
people would be surprised to learn about
you i have my pilot's license like
air like pilot yes i fly airplanes i
mean i don't currently
fly airplanes because i let my license
lapse and i'm not current but i
but i i did get super into it and bought
a plane and flew around the country
that's i could never be a pilot because
i'm colorblind
oh but i think that you don't yeah i'm
colorblind i mean i know i'm club i'm
just saying is that i'm sure that's
i didn't know that that was a
restriction i mean there are yeah i
couldn't see why it would be there's
things that involve
needing to see colors yeah i've been
there like okay those blue lights right
there i'm like
which which ones are those it's my oh my
right you're really
you're really colorblind it's not like
you can replace it saying oh for
everyone else my green
is red or whatever you're really blue
greens right yeah yeah anyway emily s
did you improvise on scrubs often yeah a
ton
and that's a credit to bill i i i give
him [ __ ] for for
for being tough on me but i i should end
by saying
uh i love him to death and he's one of
my best friends in the world
but as a as a as a uh
you know a nod to him he was very very
free with letting us play around and a
lot of people's
favorite stuff came from us just being
you know so close
and silly and the thing about scrub is
it created such a safe environment
you know when you when you're normal
when you're going into a job as an actor
in a normal situation every you know
it's like first day of school you're
nervous
you want to do a good job you want to
seem like
you're good at what you do and and
you're like you don't want to
put yourself out there too much you
don't want to overstep or be too big or
whereas after the family that was
created in scrubs and i'm sure you felt
this with with your shows too
is that it creates an environment where
there's like
there's a net underneath the the the
line and you can you can always go crazy
and do whatever comes to your mind and
just be
fully self-expressed and out of that
safety
a lot of it will be too silly and not
make sense but some of it will be
will be gems and a lot of that happened
on scrubs who's the one i mean
i'm sure it's gonna be hard to answer
because you don't want to say one person
but who's the one guy or girl
who made you laugh the most it's just so
flynn i can say it everyone everyone on
scrubs would probably say the same
answer neil flynn who played the janitor
he's a hilarious
uh improv uh comedian and
and uh a genius uh funny person do you
remember a day where you just
there's times in the script where we
just say and then neil makes up
something
because the writers would be like
midnight and they'd be like i i don't
know whatever we're going to say he's
going to beat anyway so just have him
come up with a punchline it would say
like parentheses
neil makes up something funny here and
he always would
times 10 dude he's he's he's the most
quick-witted
actor i've ever performed what's the one
thing that you remember where you just
couldn't stop laughing like they it was
getting up people were getting pissed
because we
they couldn't move on there's a bit and
you can look at this up on the gag rails
on youtube but there's a bit where the
janitors
wanted me to wear his wife had made me
short shorts
made of the scrubs material and he
wanted me to wear them
and i was like i'm not i'm a doctor i
can't wear
short shorts to work and he said but my
wife and this is all stuff he was making
up he's like but my wife
put a lot of work into these she doesn't
have the good lord didn't
bless my wife with all ten fingers she
was just
born with pointer and thumb pinky
and um he then proceeded to show how she
made the short shorts using pointer and
thumb mickey and
i couldn't get through it and that's
just him being silly and crazy
uh lisa h i love the show alex inc such
a shame got cancelled
i know what show i know what getting
cancelled like great premise great cast
did being a part of that show inspired
you to create your own podcast with
donald
uh that's a very good question i didn't
know much about podcasts at all other
than the serial podcast which i
uh devoured and thought was amazing like
so many people it was the entry into the
podcast world
and then i then i got introduced to the
story of alex blumberg
um and uh
and a podcast called startup season one
of the podcast startup
um was the inspiration for alex inc
um and that and that guy's story which
is an even crazier story because
since the show's got cancelled he sold
it for like a billion dollars and now
the character
that i was playing is uh is incredibly
loaded
so it would have been a great season too
but um
but so that i didn't know much about
podcasts then the show got canceled and
the genesis of the podcast to do with
donald which is called fake doctor's
real friends
um came because the two gals from the
office started doing one
um for for the office yeah yeah and
people were approaching donald and i
because they know we're best friends in
real life and they said would you guys
ever want to do this
we said okay sure that could be fun i
mean it was it was
we said we can't really do it more
working but when we have downtime and
neither one of us is doing anything
we'll bang out some episodes it'll be
fun we haven't seen these episodes in 20
years
well then covet hit and we were like
we have absolutely nothing else to do
but this and it became a great
thing for us it was like therapy because
just like i am with you
me and my best buddy and these two
producers who are super fun
would just sit around and laugh and tell
stories and neither one of us were ever
stand-ups right
but with the with the joke structure
with the with the with the spine of an
episode of scrubs to use as a
as a reference point it was the perfect
you know
format for us because we could
just riff and go on long tangents and
again we never thought it would be it
would be so successful but but it's
it's been it's been great people really
like it and and for
us i look forward to it because it feels
like oh i can go see my friends and have
a chat just like i am with you i love
that
fake doctor's real friends guys you got
to listen to it claudine
i love how donald always says you want
to grammy for a mixtape
what's your favorite what's your
favorite song on the garden state
soundtrack
oh wow i mean it got what a hard
question to answer but i'm gonna just go
with the first one that comes to my mind
and say um
um i only live in boy new york paul
simon
because i never thought we were going to
get only living boy in new york and um
you know just as a motivational pep talk
for your listeners every single person
i know said i will never get those songs
on the soundtrack
they were you know if if you're if
you're a filmmaker or an editor
and you do a rough cut of your first
assembly you put in whatever music you
want because you know you're not going
to necessarily be able to license it all
but you just kind of want to create the
vibe the song will be like in the spirit
of
the only living boy in new york i know
we won't be able to get that but that's
a placeholder
and then we we filled garden state with
those and every single buddy
every single person i know said that's
great but you never get any of those
songs
and um and in the end after not giving
up and and really really
doing everything i could short of giving
hand jobs
i uh got every song but one which one
didn't you get
uh fiona apple's manager i i
it's not fiona apple's fault because i
love her and she's
such a talented human being and i wish i
was friends with her but her manager was
awful to us and he was the only person
that ultimately still said no
and by the way who knew it was going to
go platinum and and become
one of grammy and become a huge thing
she actually would have made legitimate
money
but he was so mean to us that we
eventually gave up
um so other than fiona apple's song
paper bag which i then later put on
another soundtrack because i like the
song so much
um everybody said yes uh last question
jeff dee do you have any special
charities that you're involved with that
you'd like to mention
that's a nice question um i just did uh
something i really liked for
uh we did a reading of the goonies and
donald and i were um
um were all the were many of the
non-lead roles um
for a great charity that i like called
no kid hungry.org
um obviously helping uh helping make
sure
children don't go hungry during this uh
crazy time so no kid hungry.org is a is
a good one and i know it's reputable
because
um the people that organized this this
reading um did their research
uh comeback trail when's that coming out
the comeback trail
is such a good movie and you got to see
the trailer
um it's on youtube um i have a
legitimately large part in this movie i
couldn't believe it myself but it's me
and de niro
and morgan freeman again and um tommy
lee jones
and um and emile hirsch really good i
don't know because like so many movies
it was going to come out this
this fall and got pushed to to next year
it looks so
funny oh my god you look so funny that
character and you're working with the
nero side by side
was that just i mean honestly that's the
question you're going to hear for the
rest of how was it like working with
daenerys
was it was he just was he just kind of
quiet like are you doing something
very quiet i think the first thing i was
surprised about and a lot of people
surprised
that he's very quiet um when he's not
between you know not between action and
cut he's
the nero we all know and if it's intense
he's intense and if it's funny he's
being crazy and he's
i mean it's a joy to watch it's like if
you love actors it's like having a
front row seated one of the best of all
time but then you call
they call cut and he kind of quietly
goes back to his chair and
you know and i i it was my we were in
albuquerque shooting it and it was my
mission that he was going to become my
friend so little by little
it's like it's like um you know someone
in the
in the wild befriending like a wolf
like dancing with wolves i was like de
niro will be
my wolf i am going to little by little
i'm going to be this man's friend
whether he likes or not so
yeah go ahead go ahead he's just shy i
mean i think he's a shy person and
of course because of who he is everybody
in the world wants to talk to him and he
kind of
um keeps to himself and then but but but
little by little we bonded and and
became friendly and
now we we text and you text with robert
de niro
we do in flack flow and i went to dinner
at his house uh which was just
epic and um and yeah i uh we sat in his
massage chair we both got
massages from deniro's massage chair
wait a minute so he'll sit there and go
oh you got to think take a look at this
massage shirt you're going to be there
sit down no it's great
yeah yeah the squid he's really good in
the movie by the way i mean the movie
it's frustrating because i i haven't
really got an opportunity like this
in that so much of my career has been
um the tv show and then the stuff i
created
and then a handful of other things but
but i never gotten an
opportunity to go toe-to-toe
with someone like de niro in a way that
i get to in this movie
i mean i'm really i'm his nephew and he
we're we're we're b-list movie producers
in the 70s you've got it i mean i'm
i can't wait to see a minute it's really
funny if you watch the trailer you'll
crack up
so funny it's such a crowd pleaser and
de niro's never been so funny since
you know this it was written by george
gallo who wrote
midnight run so it's that style of movie
but um
but anyway it was just a disappointment
because this was a huge opportunity for
me because
i i want to show people
um you know that i can
but i don't know the other things other
than what they know me for and this was
this was a real chance to do that
you know it's it's tough because you
know you got it
you know like you have to it's not it
you call it ego whatever it is it's like
you're doing this
for a reason you're doing we're in this
business because we think we belong you
hope you belong
and you know you get opportunities
and you succeeded with those
opportunities and things become
successful
some things don't but then you sometimes
go well i never really got to do that
and i never
and you just always are waiting for more
and more and it's an insatiable
like i guess insatiable thirst of just
you
you don't the wanting to prove yourself
doesn't end it's always you want to
prove yourself not only to other people
but
i know i can do this but you want to
prove to yourself you want to prove to
everybody like look i [ __ ] belong i'm
with de niro
and i'm hanging with him and i'm i'm i'm
i should be here and again it's so
you know what we do when you're an actor
like it's so rare that
you're ever doing it you know if you're
a painter you can paint all day
i get if you're a musician you can write
all day an actor it's like you're
waiting
for the opportunity to finally come you
audition and you hustle and you memorize
i mean even when you're not a struggling
actor anymore we're still
you're still hustling and trying to get
an exciting opportunity and
and then when it finally comes when the
stars online and there's trucks on the
street and it's happening
it's just it's just you really want to
bring it and [ __ ]
this is you know an older actor once
said to me we don't get paid
to work we love working we get paid for
all the [ __ ] auditions you didn't get
and all the times you spent a week
memorizing those sides and you didn't
get the part
that's what you're getting paid for that
part sucks but when you're asking when
you're doing what you love god we should
be paying them
wow that's and i've heard it but i i
haven't heard it it's been a long time
and i'm glad you said it again
but did you audition for that for the
comeback trail or they don't they just
would have
i would have in a second but they
offered you the role they said zach
we want you to play opposite de niro in
this big movie and you were like
like a big role it just came out of
nowhere and you're like i couldn't i
couldn't believe it well my agents
obviously did a good job george knew who
i was he had george gallo wrote and
directed it
he had seen my work i think
he his wife i think also was a fan of my
work it's always good when the wife or
partner loves you
and i would have read i i got the script
first of all they call me
the agents call me and go um george
gallo wants to meet you
for uh the script i go oh that's awesome
send up the script so i start flipping
through
and i'm like is this the right part this
part's like
in every other scene they're like yeah
he wants to meet him i go okay
well i need some time to memorize it
before i like no i just want to meet you
so i go to his house he lives you know
uh up on top of the hill
and uh we just we just got together and
laughed and just shot the [ __ ]
and just you know the guy wrote midnight
run and you know he's uh he's a very
funny man we just i just had him belly
laughing
and uh i'll never forget it was early in
the morning and
his wife was still in her robe and she's
hilarious too and she came in and she's
pouring us coffee and we're just high on
caffeine just cracking each other up
and he goes um he goes look i wanna i
want you to do this
and i'm just like oh my god don't [ __ ]
this up he goes the one thing is you
gotta go meet bob for coffee because you
know
because you're doing so much with bob he
just wants to make sure
to approve you so i
i had mentioned robert de niro just like
a cocktail party once or twice like hi
nice to meet you i didn't he
i think he knew my name he'd seen me
maybe he'd seen me in a play
we also um not to go on too long
attention but my stepsister
jessica kirsten is a uh a known stand-up
comedian
and and he she was his coach when he did
the movie about
stand-up comedians so we had jessica in
common i knew that was my end to to
befriend him so i go meet deniro who was
in town
and um for coffee and we we shot the
[ __ ] we we told some funny stories
same thing kind of bonded you know he
just wanted to feel me out for
a half hour 45 minutes and i but even
when he was leaving i was like oh god
how am i going to know if he
approved me quote unquote or not and
then he kind of winked at me and said
see on set
and uh and i knew that i had gotten the
part in that moment oh my god i i i got
anxiety just hearing this story because
i picture
you're coming in you're like i'm meeting
with de niro okay you don't want to
you don't want to be the guy who's like
i love you
i love your movies oh he's like [ __ ] off
you know kid let's be you know we're
having cut
so you didn't do that you just said hey
it's good we've met before we haven't i
know
i know you know because i've been lucky
enough to to work as a director and now
as an actor with
with some of these old legends so i i
know that like there's a time and a
place where they're in a reminiscing
space
but it certainly isn't when you're just
meeting them they
you know it's you know talk about
anything else they don't want to hear
about
what you loved about godfather but were
you still while you're talking to him
you know like when you're talking to
somebody
and you're still thinking about this is
robert de niro are you sputtering like
spinning [ __ ] out of your mouth going de
niro i'm talking to de niro oh dude the
craziest part is when you watch the
movie there's scenes where he's
screaming in my face
and i i'm getting the squinty eyed in my
face
with the mole de niro look in my face
and it's just [ __ ] epic dude i
remember thinking like i can't believe
this is happening
and then there's a great scene i have
i've one scene in particular that's
really big for me where i drive it and
i'm [ __ ] mad at him and i'm screaming
and i slap his face and i'm just like
this is [ __ ]
the greatest thing oh my god to me
honestly
i i i i could retire after if that
happened i'm just done
i know i'm actually done you know you
know as you know when we when we're
actors and then you and you have no
involvement in the in the post process
you just don't know how it's going to
turn out you like do all this work and
then you're like
god i hope they don't [ __ ] it up and
this actually came out great
it's so funny and i'm excited for people
to see it the comeback trail guys watch
the trailer now i've seen the trailer it
looks freaking hilarious
i'm very jealous uh give me that quote
one more time i want you to do well
but i feel like you might want me to do
really well the quote is people want you
to do well but they don't want you to do
that well
listen i i really respect you and i i
want you to do well because you're
genuinely
you could tell this you're a genuinely
good guy you're a good person
i could see the things you tweet the
things you people like you
if you hear a lot of horror stories
about someone and bad things you're like
oh
there's probably a lot of truth to that
you don't hear that about zach braff you
don't it's mostly he's a he's a good guy
i'm sure you've ripped people's asses
out when you're directing
no yeah i'm a very good kind person i i
uh
thank you and um and same back at you
and
i like that you're my neighbor i hope
that we can be real friends i hope so
i i really appreciated your time and uh
this has been a real treat for me
and what's your handle just so people
can follow you more you like you you're
like
my name um at zac brav z-a-c-h-b-r-a-f-f
on on both instagram and the twitter
cool when you direct something i got an
album coming out i'm going to throw it
at you buddy you're going to i love that
i have a new screenplay i one thing that
came out of kovit is that
i've uh i have a new uh i i forced
myself to write which is always
hard for me it's always a process and i
have a new film i'm gonna direct
um hopefully next year fantastic well
you know
you got the exclusive here on your show
you hear that guys all right well if you
need an actor i'm about
100 houses down all right yeah yeah hey
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
you the best man this has been awesome
thank you bye-bye
i really enjoyed that interview and the
story with uh
robert de niro oh my voice robert de
niro in the massage chair
i just keep going wow man how great
would it be
you know zero gravity
the whole thing but the i don't do a de
niro but uh
actually if you don't look at me does it
kind of sound like him i don't know
you're doing this your face is doing
like 90 percent of the work
you're doing this thing with i don't
know
no good i need i need to be looking at
you because the because it it it
is here it's mostly a de niro is mostly
a vigil
every time you say this it's nasally i
don't know i got nipples greg
could you milk me could you is that from
analyze this
no meet the parents meet the parents
that's what i meant a big thanks to
zach braff for being on the show
hopefully he'll come back we've got
great episodes coming up please
subscribe if you haven't already
just go to uh apple podcast write a
review and um on the youtube you could
subscribe
and uh comment i read comments i respond
in fact i respond a lot to comments and
if you want to really leave an email
um just uh you know
at hello at inside of youpodcast.com
and um i checked them i don't respond
always because you know it's impossible
but uh
if you order something on the online
store by the way and then you send a
message there
and you're like oh i want to cancel my
order it's kind of too late i i
i send things fast people want to get
things fast
and remember if you want to really join
uh the
want to be a groupie for the band we'd
love to have you
uh our spinners the band is sunspin you
could be our spinners
um at sunspin band our handles please
follow us
and sunspin.com you can get merch
zooms you can book us for a picnic all
sorts of fun [ __ ]
and uh merch and the also the inside of
your online store you can get all the uh
inside of you stuff
uh why don't we give a shout out to uh
my lovable
patrons let's do it there we go should i
do an impression this time when i'm
doing it
sure what should i do walking walking
little lisa yukiko jill e
brian h lauren g
nico p robin s jerry w
emily k robert i jason w
de niro stephen stephen j
is it jay kristen k
emilio alisonnel jess j lucasam
raj there it is oh raj g
joshua d emily s cjp samantha
m jennifer n jackie p
who else uh morgan freeman stacy l
carly h is that terrible
you did a good one uh in the interview
when i first met handy janelle b
carrie b tabitha 272
not to be confused with just tabitha 273
i can't i'm not going to do it back
ashley ryan
kimberly e crystal h
mikey marissa in
all right give me another one do you do
seinfeld or do you accidentally do
seinfeld
eldon el don sopremo i i don't do
uh thurston howell
uh eldon supremo uh jack
s ramirez gilligan
um malkovich yeah beth b
santiago m sarah f chad w
leanne p roshan rashan
ray a
maya p maddie s tiffany i
kendrick f ashley e
something like that did you nick cage no
how about
the guy from science to the lambs
shannon d
matt w belinda and
wait wait wait we got kevin v here james
r
chris h anusha w
nice one you got a nice one
osborne h abc
dave h samantha s spider-man chase
schiller g
ryan h alyssa c tab of the t
misha h deb a tom and natalie six two
two not to be confused with natalie six
two three suzanne b
henry s katie f liliana a michelle k
marcus
w and a b well you did a little owen
wilson here
with uh michael uh michael s
wow that's great oh yeah i'm luke h
john s andrew t christie s
claire m liz j laura l chad b
rachel e nathan e brandel d and
taylor k uh i love you guys and thank
you for the support
as always um i hope you enjoyed zach
braff if you did please again subscribe
and
listen to us next week we have another
great guest and uh always love being
here with my friend ryan
yeah yeah i guess uh thanks for allowing
to be inside of each and every one of
you
ryan little wave oh yeah what song are
we playing over here
from my band sunspin this is one of the
new this is the show
thanks guys